women are not getting abused left right
and Center no no no no no no that is not
the case and I will have to beat this
out of you guys no stop saying that
women are the more likely party to be
abused most abusive situations the
parties are abusing each other sorry
guys but you attract what you are if you
are constantly attracting abusive
Partners it is possible that maybe you
are abusive as well when it comes to one
side abuse where one party is hitting
the other and they are not reciprocating
even with the Under reporting that we
know men under report this stuff women
are more likely to be abusive than be
abused women are just as abusive if not
more abusive than men